Si el otro día nos deteníamos a hacer un
repaso sobre los candidatos  republicanos,
hoy vamos a hacer lo mismo con los candidatos DEMOCRATAS. En este caso, el catálogo es
bastante más reducido. Pero aún así, tenemos
también nuestros propios personajes, nuestro
propio, incluso, DONALD TRUMP. Así es, Bernie SANDERS, que apesar de sus 74 años y de ser
muy radical (de izquierdas, pero muy radical) se ha convertiro contra todo pronóstico en
una estrella mediática. De hecho, está vendiendo muy cara su derrota
En primer lugar tenemos a HILLARY CLINTON
Bueno, por si alguien vive debajo de una piedra y no sabe quien es Hillary Clinton
Recordamos que es una abogada de prestigio, tiene 68 años, ha sido activista en su etapa más joven...
Luego fue primera dama junto a su marido, a Bill Clinton...
Después, Secretaria de Estado y senadora
Y hay que recordar que ahora mismo l e está saliendo un poco de porquería de su etapa de secretaria de estado
Porque se la ocurrió usar su correo personal para tratar temas secretos
En vez de utilizar el correo cifrado del Gobierno de EEUU.
Bernie Sanders tampoco es un neófito de la política norteamericana.
Alcalde, congresista y senador, ahora busca romper todos los moldes definiéndose como  SOCIALISTA
Un término tabú en la política americana.
Además, aunque los medios de comunicación lo suelan obviar, Bernie es MUY nacionalista.
De hecho, encarna muy bien el lema de "América para los americanos".
De hecho, su masa de votos es equivalente a la de Donald Trump.
A Bernie le votan, sobretodo población blanca, rural y jóvenes.
¿Y qué papel juega Hillary en estas primarias?
Hillary Clinton es la candidata MODERADA dentro del partido demócrata
¿Y por qué es la candidata moderada? Tiene un discurso muy flexible, no se moja mucho y hasta lo cambia a veces.
De hecho, hasta hace poco, en su página web no podíamos encontrar NADA acerca de su programa electoral.
Pero, en cambio, lo que sí podíamos encontrar eran millones de fotos de su historia de amor con su marido.
En el caso de Hillary, sus votantes se encuentran entre las minorías, las mujeres y la población urbana.
Una masa electoral más amplia que la de Bernie, que hace que tenga más posibilidades para ser la nominada por el Partido Demócrata.
Pero ¿Qué tienen en común Bernie y Hillary? En ciertas areas, tienen un camino bastante paralelo.
Aunque sean los dos de izquierdas, hay que decir que Hillary es un poquito menos.
Por ejemplo, en el marco de la sanidad, Hillary apuesta por seguir con el OBAMACARE, es decir,
Una colaboración público-privada.
Mientras Bernie defiende un seguro público que trate de garantizar el acceso universal.
Algo parecido a lo que tenemos en España.
"Es hora de que EEUU se una al resto de países industrializados y garantice sanidad para todos  como un derecho"
En el terreno de la educación, tres cuartas partes de lo mismo, mientras que Hillary defiende...
que el gobierno federal de dinero a los estados para quee stos reduzcan las tasas universitarias
Y además también propone tratar de reducir los intereses en los préstamos universitarios...
Bernie Sanders va mucho más allá y propone que las universidades públicas sean gratuitas.
En el próximo mes sacaré una ley que haga que toda escuela/universidad pública tenga tasas gratuítas.
En el terreno del salario mínimo, Hillary propone 12 dólares la hora mientras que Bernie propone 15.
En el terreno de las infraestructuras, Hillary propone una inversión de 250.000M de €
Bernie va MUCHO más allá y propone una inversión 4 VECES MAYOR de UN BILLÓN DE EUROS
En otros campos, las políticas de ambos candidatos siguen caminos contrapuestos.
El caso más claro es su visión del comercio y la globalización.
Bernie, como decíamos antes, encarna el nacionalismo que tiene como lema "America para los americanos".
Y, por ello, se opone a los tratados de libre comercio. Los culpa, de hecho, de haber destruído millones de trabajos.
Y el propone defender la industria nacional de la competencia exterior.
Hillary, al contrario, entiende que el comercio entre los pueblos es bueno para la actividad económica y la generación de puestos de trabajo.
Y a lo largo de su trayectoria política, SIEMPRE ha defendido los acuerdos de libre comercio.
En el caso del NAFTA y también en la negociación del acuerdo de libre comercio del Pacífico.
Lo que ocurre es que ahora a Hillary la interesa decir que no está de acuerdo con ese tipo de políticas.
Y ha introducido muchos matices a sus declaraciones del pasado pero la evidencia empírica es clara.
Ella, como Obama, siempre ha sido defensora del libre comercio.
En política exterior, también son muy diferentes...
Hillary es todo un halcón cuyos postulados se apoyan a los del partido republicano.
"No nos quedaremos de brazos cruzados mientras amenazan a nuestros socios y aliados del Golfo.
Nosotros actuaremos".
Mientras que Bernie Sanders es más heterodoxo en la materia.
Tiene dos propuestas principales.
UNA: Abandonar Afganistán, porque dice que esta misión solo le ha costado dolor y sacrificio al pueblo americano.
Y en la guerra contra el ISIS, darle el liderazgo a los países musulmanes
En concreto, Bernie habla de Arabia Saudí
Algo que es muy controvertido... yo, personalmente, me cuesta creer que una teocracia como Arabia Saudita sea la solución a nada.
Pero ¡Así es Bernie!
Y, por último, política económica. Aquí los candidatos han mantenido intensos rifirrafes.
Bernie culpa a Hillary de ser la candidata de Wall Street y de estar comprada por los grandes bancos.
"Déjeme preguntarle... ¿Por qué cree que los grandes bancos le pagan más de 200.000 Dólares por un discurso?"
Bernie, en cambio, lo que quiere hacer es romper estos grandes bancos porque dice que
Si una entidad financiera es demasiado grande para caer, también es demasiado grande para existir.
Y que con bancos pequeñitos, el riesgo sería mucho más controlable.
Y en impuestos. A Bernie le gusta gastar y para eso necesita recaudar. Por eso propone un plan fiscal desmesurado.
Quiere subir TODOS los impuestos habidos y por haber y hasta inventarse algunos nuevos.
Si pensábamos en España que con el tandem Rajoy-Montoro habíamos conocido la quintaesencia de la voracidad fiscal, Bernie les supera.
Para hacernos una idea, Bernie quiere subir cada año por el equivalente a TODOS los impuestos que se recaudan en España.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
Quiere subirle los impuestos a TODO el mundo.A los ricos y a los no tan ricos.
De hecho, el salario medio con Bernie pagaría 4500 dólares más cada año.
Hillary, como no, aquí es un poco más moderada. Aunque habla de subir los impuestos a los ricos y arreglar lagunas tributarias...
También contempla favorecer la reinversión de las empresas, las PYMES, y darle acomodos tributarios a las familias que tengan que hacer gastos especiales.
Como, por ejemplo, pagar la universidad del hijo.
Con todo esto que hemos dicho, si tuviera que elegir un candidato entre Bernie y Hillary, me quedaba con HILLARY.
Aunque no sea santo de mi devoción, Bernie me da un poco de miedo.
No creo que sea un mal tipo pero este buenismo socialista que trata de arreglar todo a base de decretazos...
Como en España podemos tener a Podemos... la verdad es que me dan un poco de miedo.
Y ya, los republicanos, en estas primarias, están de vuelta y media...
Cualquier presidente americano , tiene que tener claro que la inmigración no es un problema.
Hillary siempre lo ha tenido claro.
Hillary podrá ser lo que quieras pero ha reconocido EEUU como la tierra de la libertad y la tierra de los sueños.
Y por eso mismo, yo me mojo y voto por Hillary Clinton.
Estoy de acuerdo contigo, Alberto, aunque ya sabes que mi candidato favorito era JOHN KASICH.
Lo que pasa es que no parece que vaya a tener muchas probabilidades de obtener la nominación (republicana).
En cualquier caso, Hillary si introduce en su programa elementos muy positivos, algunos de los cuales...
podríamos tomar nota en España. Por ejemplo, ella habla de darle facilidades fiscales a las empresas que
decidan repartir una parte de los beneficios con sus trabajadores.
¿Qué quiere favorecer con esto? Que el salario de los trabajadores esté ligado a la productividad.
Algo que a mi me parece muy bueno para la flexibilidad del tejido productivo.
Y además, Hillary también tiene preocupaciones que no llenan titulares...
Por ejemplo, Hillary contempla un plan de 5000 millones de dólares para favorecer la reinserción penitenciaria.
En EEUU es una de las más grandes del mundo y donde REALMENTE tienen un problema.
Por todo ello, Alberto, salvo que John Kasich de la sorpresa, yo también voy con Hillary.
Y como milagrosamente, Enrique y yo estamos de acuerdo, no podemos dejar escapar la ocasión
Y hemos preparado una sorpresa para Hillary Clinton. Hemos hecho nuestro propio spot electoral.
La vida es como un surtido de galletas.
Todos empezamos comiéndonos las de chocolate...
después pasamos a las que están rellenas de crema.
Y, finalmente, siempre queda esa galleta que no sabe a nada.
Es cierto. Nadie quiere comérsela. Pero alguien debe hacerlo para acabar con el surtido.
Es un deber moral.
Tirar la caja a la basura sin habérsela terminado no es propio de América.
Hillary es esa galleta.
Sí, nadie sabe a ciencia cierta lo que defiende.
Probablemente no sea la mejor presidenta de EEUU.
Pero está en política desde antes de que Jordi Hurtado saliera en TV.
Y al igual que el presentador de "Saber y Ganar", ella TAMPOCO ha envejecido.
Amigos americanos, tenéis que votar a Hillary Clinton.
¿Por qué?
¿Qué narices? '¡Por que es Hillary Clinton!
Porque vas a terminar votándola Y LO SABES.
Hillary for America
Cómete la galleta, antes de que el monstruo de las galletas nos coma a todos.